vous mon ami êtes une énigme pour moi parce
que j'ai parcouru votre visage dans vos empreintes à
travers toutes les bases de données que nous avons vous savez que
nous n'avons rien trouvé alors pourquoi ne pas commencer
par votre nom 47 ce n'est pas un nom non mais
c'est le mien je sais  tu n'as aucune
raison de me faire confiance mais tu es en danger
que dois-je faire
tu sais pourquoi tu es toujours en vie parce que
j'ai choisi de ne pas te tuer
mais ils le feront tu te souviens du jour où
ils t'ont pris nous étions  partie du même
programme ils veulent ce qu'il y a dans notre ADN
la vitesse la force de l'intelligence d'accord
tu es comme moi alors je meurs toi
-même dis-moi comment faire
un agent tu ne veux pas d'un graveur tu veux une
armée ils sont la clé  à tout
le cadeau n'est pas seulement survivre vous voyez
tout
va brûler ce programme au sol
vous savez vous agneau